How I Met Your Mother star Josh Radnor anchored
the CBS sitcom for nine seasons as the unlucky-in-love
Ted Mosby, working his way into viewers' hearts
with his adorable smiles, constant optimism,
and pretentious pronunciation skills.
"Oh you think it should be pronounced encyclopedia?
It's a common mistake, but if you look at
the squished together A-E symbol in this here encyclopedia,
you'll learn that it's a ligature derived
from the Anglo-Saxon rune…"
However, since the hit show ended in 2013,
Radnor has been noticeably missing from the
limelight.
Since so many people loved his character on
the series, everyone wants to know why he
hasn't been in another other high-profile
projects, so let's explore why Hollywood won't cast
Josh Radnor anymore.
MIA at the movies
Radnor didn't have very many credits to his
name before getting cast as the lead in How
I Met Your Mother.
Aside from a small appearance in Not Another
Teen Movie, he'd only had guest appearances
on various TV shows.
How I Met Your Mother launched him to stardom,
and his most notable role since then has been
in the TV sphere, as Dr. Jed Foster on PBS'
Mercy Street.
In other words, Radnor just hasn't shown that
he can anchor a film yet, which could make
studios wary of casting him and risking poor
box office returns.
Ted Mosby Eternal
It's often tough for actors who spent a long
time playing one part to shed that identity.
To many viewers, Sarah Michelle Gellar will
always be Buffy, Daniel Radcliffe will always
be Harry Potter, and Josh Radnor will always
be Ted Mosby.
This can make it difficult for actors to move
on from career-defining characters and can
make it hard for casting directors to see
them in potential roles.
Just ask Mark Hamill…
Looking for love
Like Ted Mosby, Radnor has ALSO been trying
his best to find Mrs. Right in real life.
"If you're looking for the word that means
caring about someone beyond all rationality
and wanting to have everything they want no
matter how much it destroys you…
It's love."
He hasn't married or made mysterious-mothered
children with anyone yet, but there have been
plenty of rumors surrounding his partners.
Radnor split with actress Lindsay Price, whom
he met on the set of How I Met Your Mother,
after a year of dating in 2009.
He was linked to Twilight actress Julia Jones
in 2013 and later dated actress Marisa Tomei
in 2014.
After that, reports say that he's dating Friday
Night Lights beauty Minka Kelly.
If we learned anything from Ted, it's that
finding that special someone can involve a
lot of trial and error.
Tapping it out
The actor is also working on other writing
projects that may keep him from screen work,
including securing a deal for his as-yet-untitled
book on his attempts to "answer the big questions
about spirituality."
The book is expected to follow "an ongoing
quest that takes [Radnor] from his youth in
heartland Ohio to the unexpected lessons of
celebrity and beyond."
Tied up behind the lens
Radnor won the Sundance Film Festival Dramatic
Audience Award for his 2010 directorial debut
Happythankyoumoreplease, which he also wrote
and starred in.
Since then, Radnor has also written, directed
and starred in the film Liberal Arts and is
set to direct — but not star in — the
upcoming sci-fi drama The Leaves.
Radnor said he got into writing with Happythankyoumoreplease
in order to "give [himself] a great film role,"
adding that by writing, directing, and acting
in his films, he can create projects that
feel personal.
Dabbling in music
Radnor is part of the band Radnor & Lee, along
with Australian musician Ben Lee, and in October
2016, Radnor announced that they were working
on a debut album:
"So I understand you're writing songs for
your first album, that's great.
"I am. I am..."
"You play instruments?"
"I do not play an instrument. I'm writing an album."
"We're instrument-free as well."
"We have a support group going."
Called, "Love Songs for God and Women," Radnor
said the album will feature mellow folk songs
co-written and performed by the duo.
"We decided to write one song together and
we had so much fun that we wrote 11.
Then we said let's make an album, so we're
cuttin' a record!"
Taking the stage
While he's been missed on the big and small
screens, Radnor has been a regular feature
on popular stages for the past few years.
For example, in 2015, he appeared in the Pulitzer
Prize-winning play Disgraced, and most recently,
he could be seen in The Babylon Line at The
Lincoln Center Theater opposite Elizabeth
Reaser.
A turnaround
Radnor has made some eclectic choices since
the ending of How I Met Your Mother, and while
he may not be following the stereotypical
path of most actors, he's still been keeping
himself busy with valuable and original projects,
like his festival-friendly drama The Seeker.
Radnor's smarts and ambition should serve
him well in any field.
Here's hoping we just get to see a little
bit more of him soon.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!